أه كلمتين نادرًا ما يتم وضعهما معًا في
تاريخ البشرية حتى الآن وهما
ذكاء اصطناعي ومع ذلك في عام 2023
يجب أن نطرح سؤالًا جديدًا وهو
هل يمكن أن يساعدنا الذكاء الاصطناعي على وجه التحديد في
اكتشاف
المضادات الحيوية التي يستخدمها باحثو الذكاء الاصطناعي ويقولون إنهم
وجدوا مضادًا حيويًا يعمل ضد
كانت البكتيريا التي يكاد يكون من المستحيل علاجها من المركب
دقيقة للغاية بحيث يمكنها استهداف
العامل الممرض وترك البكتيريا المفيدة
في مكانها ، دعنا نتعرف أكثر على هذه
القصة المذهلة من
إليزابيث كو إليزابيث من CNN لماذا
يأمل الباحثون في مكافحة هذه
البكتيريا وكيف  هل يساعد الذكاء الاصطناعي في
تحقيق
ماكس هذه البكتيريا التي تسمى أسيتوباكتر
بالمونيا ، إنها حقًا مروعة جدًا
لأنها ذكية جدًا لدرجة أنها تمكنت على
مر السنين من التغلب على جميع المضادات الحيوية تقريبًا أو حتى في
بعض الأحيان حتى جميع المضادات الحيوية
التي يمكننا رميها عليها ، لقد رأينا تلك
المضادات الحيوية وهي  تمكنت من تعلم
كيفية خداعهم ، لذلك يحاول الناس أيضًا
استخدام الذكاء الآن للتغلب على
البكتيريا ، بالطريقة التي يحدث بها هذا عادةً
هي تجربة هذا الدواء
ومعرفة ما إذا كان يعمل ، جرب هذا الدواء
ولكن هذا بطيء نسبيًا وهناك
لا يوجد وقت نضيعه ، وإليك السبب في أن هذه
البكتيريا تتغذى حقًا على الأشخاص في
المستشفيات ، وبالتالي فإن
الأشخاص الأكثر ضعفًا هم الذين يثنون عليها
يمكن أن تسبب التهابات في الدم
والمسالك البولية ، ويمكن أن تسبب
التهابات في الرئة وبعبارة أخرى يمكن  يسبب
الالتهاب الرئوي ويتمسك بالأسطح
وهذا حقًا سبب كون هذا الشرير
هو أنه حتى لو كنت جيدًا جدًا في
التنظيف هناك فمن الممكن أن
تفوتك حتى يتمكن الذكاء الاصطناعي من
القيام بذلك بسرعة أكبر ويمكنه
تجربته  هذا الدواء المختلف الذي
دواء مختلف ، يمكن أن يجرب
مئات الملايين من الأدوية أو حتى
مليار دواء بينما عندما تفعل
ذلك نوعًا من الطريقة القديمة ، ربما
يمكنك أن تفعل مثل مليون دواء ، فما
فعله هؤلاء الناس  هؤلاء علماء
في الولايات المتحدة هل أخذوا
فأراً وأصابوه بجرح بهذه
البكتيريا ثم أه أعطوهم
هذا المضاد الحيوي للفأر ولم
يقتل البكتيريا فقط ولكنه
لم يؤذي بكتيريا جيدة  هذا
أحد الأشياء التي تبحث عنها عن مضاد حيوي
أراد أن يحافظ على البكتيريا الجيدة
ويقتل البكتيريا السيئة الآن سأقول ماكس
أنه لا ينبغي أن نعتقد أن هذا
سيكون في السوق في أي وقت قريب ، فهذا
يوم رائع إذا  فأرًا مصابًا ، هذا
ليس يومًا رائعًا إذا كنت
شخصًا جريحًا مثل اليوم ، فسيتعين علينا الانتظار وسنضطر إلى الانتظار
للتأكد من أن
هذا الدواء لا تعرف أنه سيتعين عليهم
تجربته  هل يسبب
مشاكل أخرى للبشر ، هل يمكننا أن نجعل
شركة أدوية ترى أن هذا أمر
مربح ، فإن هذين الأمرين يمثلان
تحديًا وسيستغرقان سنوات على
الأقل ماكس ، فهل هذه طريقة محتملة
لتخصيص المضادات الحيوية لمسببات الأمراض الأخرى
المقاومة للأدوية
نعم بالتأكيد أنا  يعني أن هذا
دليل حقًا على مبدأ أن الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكنه فقط
القيام بالمهمة بشكل أسرع ولا
يفعل أي شيء لا يستطيع البشر القيام به بالضرورة ،
إنه يؤدي المهمة بشكل أسرع وهذه كانت
المشكلة الحقيقية في تطوير المضادات الحيوية
ماكس على مر السنين هي أن
يستغرق الأمر عقودًا وعقودًا فقط ،
ونأمل أن يتمكن الذكاء الاصطناعي من تقليص هذا الوقت